every one people often ask me how I make
money what's my business model and I
tell them that I like to kick up as much
noise in my industry as possible create
as much attention as possible and then I
capitalize on that attention and if you
want to make money you need to get
attention attention is the currency when
you have attention you can then sell
product wouldíve attention you can get
investors when you have attention you
can you can sell advertising you can
make brand deals when you have attention
that's what matters and so this is a
special video where I'm going to be
talking about how I generate a lot of
attentions from my business and it's
made for my mastermind group members
it's the fifth Monday in my online
mastermind group meets every Monday and
on the fifth Monday I have to share
something an issue a challenge and so I
want to talk about getting attention
through social a lot of people when they
think about social media what they think
about is the content I need to have
great content right content is what's
gonna make me send out and yes it's true
you need to have great content and yes
most of you guys aren't doing a good
enough job yet because I've seen a lot
of the content that you're putting out
and and it's okay it's okay but it's not
great and you need to get better and
that will happen you know with time with
practice you know I've made over 2,000
videos I get better every time as you
create more content you will get better
and as you make it a goal to get better
a content then you will get better at
content if that's on your priority list
then it's going to happen but where most
people miss the ball is doing the second
part which is creating the tension
around the content create attention for
yourself and the way to do that is to
reach out to people and be seen on their
networks the people who are super active
on my youtube channel and my twitter
account who are retweeting things
leaving positive comments sharing their
advice giving their suggestions I check
those people out random might be from
one comment but is usually from the
people who are leaving repeated comments
I'm always curious to know who's
actively engaged on my channel so that
should be you for other people the
fastest way to grow your business is the
partner of people make the lines of the
people who already have your target
audience and it's so much easier to do
now in the social world where you can
see who their audiences
I want go ahead and fine
who is a top who are the top five people
in my industry who are targeting my my
customers not doing the exact same thing
that I'm doing but they have my audience
and then how can I reach out to them
both the the creator the at that
individual but also be involved in their
community
most of the top youtubers they barely
aren't engaged with their community most
of the top people on Twitter they barely
are engage with their community they're
not responding the tweets are not
responding to comments you know on my
youtube channel as many comments as we
get and I'm not like top top top yet but
getting there everybody gets a comment
whether it's me whether it's someone on
my team and my vision is actually
scaling up my team just as my comments
scale up just like in any normal
business customer support scales right
you don't want people calling somebody
calling your business and there's nobody
answering the phone right that's how I
see comments on YouTube and responses on
Twitter you should be giving people
replies but I'm the exception
most channels people aren't paying
attention as much their audience you
could be the guy or the girl who is
leaving the most comments who is
actively involved in that person's
community and you're not only going to
get that person's attention but you're
gonna get the rest of the community's
attention as well and so every time
somebody's leaving a lot of comments on
my channel I go check them out and I'll
often watch at least one video and look
at a couple tweets and often honestly at
that point you lose me a little bit
because Apollo the contents not there
right so back to the first problem
improve the quality of content make it
better that's what's gonna make me want
to subscribe and follow you and watch
more your stuff but you got me there
right that's the point you've got me to
come to your page you got me to check
out your channel you got me to visit you
right that's what you want more and more
people doing and so I would set a
personal goal to post at least 10
different comments is my challenge for
you guys at least 10 different comments
on other people's channels whether it's
one person that you go deep on you look
at one video and you're leaving ten
comments and different people you can
save the Creator but more importantly is
get involved in the community everybody
in that community should know who you
are because you are super engaged you
will likely be more
gage than the content creator it's not
gonna happen on my channel but on most
other people's channels you will be
likely the most engaged person and
that's great right that will get you
noticed by that creator and by the
community then people visit your site
then people check out your YouTube
channel then people will check out
everything you're doing on social and
then it's going to come down to are you
producing enough quality content so it's
both right it's having the content and
having the attention creating the
awareness around it most people only
focus on creating the content and
nothing around the attention and so I
want you guys to start building up some
attention new community 10 posts per day
on other people's channels
good luck let me know how I know it's
working out leave in the comments below
and I'll see you guys soon